Nein, nein. Zahlen, zahlen, zahlen in der Musik und das heißt, es ist der letzte Donnerstag im Monat und das heißt, es ist wieder mal Zeit fürs Chaosradio. Der Blue Moon, einmal im Monat, wo der Chaos Computer Club sich im Studio einschließt, ganz viel Unsinn treibt und möglicherweise nebenbei auch noch ein spannendes technisches Thema erklärt. Heute zu Gast unter anderem der Herr Starbuck, hallo und guten Abend.
Meistens macht er etwas kaputt.
Heute ist das eine Fingerabdruckscanner, der kaputt gemacht wurde. Mal wieder muss man auch dazu sagen. Zu Gast sind Starbuck und Frau Dr. Konstanze Kurz. Guten Abend.
Ey Markus, jetzt ist er aber wirklich nicht mehr lustig.
Das entscheide immer noch ich. Wir reden über einen Fingerabdruckscanner. Wir haben die erste Stunde dazu genutzt, um zu erklären, wie das technisch geht. Also wie man das macht, dass man einen Fingerabdruckscanner so überlistet, dass er einen gefälschten Fingerabdruck, also einen nachgemachten, akzeptiert. Und das kann man auch nachmachen. Ich würde gerne noch mal kurz zusammenfassen, wie das geht. Aber das würde wahrscheinlich wirklich zu kompliziert sein. Das heißt, ihr müsstet euch, wenn ihr jetzt erst einsteigt, das als Podcast anhören. Den gibt es ja dann auf fritz.de und chaosradio.de.
Oder Video klicken.
Oder das Video klicken und wir kommen jetzt gleich sozusagen zu der gesellschaftlichen Konsequenz daraus und der Pressearbeit, die daraus entstanden ist und gemacht werden musste. Vorher aber noch mal das Angebot an euch. Falls ihr Fragen habt zu dem Thema, könnt ihr gerne anrufen. 0331 70 97 110. Und das hat nämlich auch der Robin gemacht. Robin21 aus Frankfurt. Hallo Robin. Du hattest noch ein paar Fragen.
Ja, ich hab noch zwei Fragen dazu. Zum einen, was das iPhone angeht, würde mich mal interessieren, wiefern ihr das so auseinander genommen habt und mal geschaut habt, okay, ist das eigentlich bei dem Fingerabdruck so, wie es auch gesagt wird, dass da quasi halt so eine Prüfsumme eben auf dem Chip gespeichert wird, der Fingerabdruck eigentlich gar nicht weiter verarbeitet werden kann oder inwiefern vielleicht doch die Möglichkeit besteht, mal eben schnell übers Internet, mal zu Apple zum Beispiel, wo es dann schön irgendwo gespeichert wird. Inwiefern dieser Fingerabdruck also wirklich mehr auf dem Chip verarbeitet wird oder vielleicht doch irgendwie weiter geschickt werden könnte, ob da schon irgendwie was feststeht mittlerweile?
Haben wir noch nicht gemacht und ich gehe davon aus, also wenn das jemand tut, dann dauert das noch ein bisschen, weil das ist tatsächlich deutlich schwieriger zu machen als halt den Fingerabdruck nachzubauen. Ich vermute mal ganz stark, also irgendwas knackt hier. Also normalerweise, also halt frühere Sensoren speichern halt normalerweise Minute-Positionen. Das heißt, wenn du einen Fingerabdruck hast, dann hast du halt diese Hautrillen und die verzweigen sich irgendwann. Das nennt man Minute und die werden normalerweise benutzt. Und wenn man auch nur die abspeichert, kann man halt den Fingerabdruck nicht rekonstruieren. Was ich aus den Winning Informationen rausgelesen hab, die Apple dazu gegeben hat, speichern sie anscheinend tatsächlich den gesamten Verlauf der Fingerlinien auch mit. Das heißt, ich gehe davon aus oder ich vermute, dass wenn man tatsächlich irgendwie an die abgespeicherten Template hat, also sie werden halt kein Bild abspeichern, damit bin ich relativ sicher, ist auch viel zu groß und so. Aber wenn sie tatsächlich diese Fingerrillen, Daten abspeichern, denke ich schon, dass man daraus den Fingerabdruck wieder rekonstruieren kann. Aber es ist halt nur meine Vermutung.
Vielleicht sollte man dazu noch sagen, dass ich glaube, dieser Touch-ID-Hack hat schon auch so eine Welle ausgelöst, international von Leuten, die jetzt auch Bock haben, um zu untersuchen, wir sind ja nicht die Einzigen, die sich dafür interessieren. Mir scheint, dass da auch so eine Art Wettbewerb entstanden ist. Und da wird es sicherlich nicht nur um den Sensor an sich gehen, sondern auch um die Daten, wo sie hingespeichert sind, wie sie gespeichert sind, ob sie übertragen werden können. Ich glaube, das ist eine Frage der Zeit.
Also ich weiß auf jeden Fall, dass Leute dran sind. Aber ich weiß auch, dass es halt schon deutlich komplizierter Prozess ist und das wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen dauert. Auf jeden Fall irgendwie, man guckt sich das an.
Das ist ja auch sozusagen, also nur um es mal kurz zu erklären, das ist ja auch eine sehr interessante Frage, weil wenn in dem Gerät der Fingerabdruck gespeichert ist, dann kann man ja nicht nur, wenn man das Gerät hat sozusagen, also in der Hand das Gerät hat, möglicherweise den Abdruck auslesen und danach machen, sondern man könnte ja möglicherweise auch so ein iPhone mal hacken und den Fingerabdruck irgendwo hin verschicken lassen, dann so eine kleine Datenbank von gehackten iPhone-Finger und so weiter und so fort. Das gucken wir uns nochmal an. Hast du noch eine Frage Robin?
Ja, ich hab noch eine Frage und zwar, wie sieht das aus mit dem Fingerabdrucknachbau bei Sachen, wo es wirklich drauf ankommt? Also sagen wir mal, zum Beispiel bei deinem neuen Personalausweis oder beim Reisepass, ist das da genauso einfach nachzumachen oder ist das nochmal schon irgendwie ein bisschen was anderes?
Das ist tatsächlich noch einfacher. Also das ist das, was Sie vorhin schon erklärt haben. Da geht es halt wirklich mit dem Ausdruck von der Folie abziehen. Also da musst du nicht ätzen und nix. Aber die Sensoren sind halt optisch.
Der Scanner ist einfach, die Qualität ist viel geringer.
Die Auffallung ist tatsächlich ähnlich, aber sie ist schon optischer. Da reicht halt wirklich diese dünne Schicht, die von der Folie abgezogen wird. Also haben wir auch schon vor, vor Jahren, als Sie den damals auf der CeBIT vorgestellt haben, den Scanner haben wir das irgendwie einmal gemacht. Und es ist genauso.
Könnten wir aber bei der Gelegenheit darauf hinweisen, dass es optional ist und vollkommen freiwillig, seinen Fingerabdruck beim Ausweis abzugeben. Und wir raten davon ab.
Natürlich, der wird ja genauso auch nicht gespeichert.
Nee, natürlich nicht. Und auch nicht von der NSA ausgelesen.
Nein, ganz, ganz bestimmt nicht. Jetzt hätte ich aber noch zu dem NPA auch noch ein persönliches kurzes Problem. Dürfte ich das noch kurz fragen?
Ja, aber dann sollten wir sagen, dass der NPA nämlich genau dieser elektronische Personalausweis ist. E-P-A. Wir nennen ihn E-P-A, weil wir diese Umbenennung nicht mitgemacht haben.
Ich bin vielleicht zu brainwashed irgendwie. Das kann natürlich sein.
Na, sag mal.
Weil mein Problem ist, ich hab die letzten fünf Jahre im Ausland gelebt, hab aber diese Thematik sehr intensiv mitverfolgt, bin jetzt dann Anfang des Jahres wieder zurück nach Deutschland, hab mir den dann halt auch geholt. Und wusste nicht genau, wie verbreitet der schon ist und hab gedacht, weil bei mir ist es so, ich bin vollständig blind und hab eben gedacht, okay, vielleicht eine ganz coole Sache mit dieser elektronischen Signatur und so, bla, bla. Hab mir das besorgt und hab aber festgestellt, dass dieses Programm, mit dem man auf den Personatausweis zugreift, über so einen Kartenleser mit einem Screenreader, also das ist quasi dieses Programm, was für einen blinden Menschen eben den Text in eine Sprache umwandelt, dass das überhaupt gar nicht bedienbar ist.
Hast du die BSI-App dafür, also hast du die drunter geladen von einer...
Ja, diese Ausweis-App, ja genau.
Genau, okay. Ja, und es gibt auch mittlerweile einige Firmen, die das anbieten. Da müsstest du vielleicht mal probieren, ob du noch eine bessere findest, wenn die... Also die hilft dir eigentlich überhaupt nicht, ne?
Ja, weil das funktioniert dir überhaupt gar nicht. Weil das Problem ist, das ist ja alles, das ist ja diese ganze Java-Code und so. Und das ist prinzipiell eigentlich nicht wirklich nutzbar. Also allgemein, diese ganze Java-Geschichte. Und eigentlich gibt es auch eine Verordnung dafür, die eben vorschreibt, dass eben so staatliche, behördliche Anwendungen auch zugänglich sein müssen.
Okay, Robin, wir verlassen gerade, glaube ich, den Bereich des Fingerkurs.
Das tut mir auch leid. Ich wollte noch mal fragen, ob es da vielleicht irgendwie eine Möglichkeit gäbe, irgendwas dagegen zu machen.
Zumindest eins würde ich auf jeden Fall machen. Ich glaube, das ist ein brechiges Interesse. Und ich denke, da würde ich mich bei der Behörde, das ist ja jede BSI, auch mal zu Wort melden. Da würden wir dich im Zweifel auch unterstützen.
Das fände ich super, weil ich habe ehrlich gesagt auch schon, das ist wirklich der letzte Weg, denn ich gehe über das Radio.
Magst du mal noch eine Mail an biometrie.ccc.de schicken? Dann kriegen wir das auch.
Finde ich auch wichtig. Wir haben eh sehr viele Versprechungen bei diesem Ausweis, nicht eingelöst, das wäre eine mehr. Und da bist du ja sicherlich auch nicht alleine.
So ist es nämlich, genau.
Mach das mal.
Biometrie, ccc.de, viel Spaß beim Schreiben.
Jetzt werde ich erstmal noch viel Spaß haben am Zuhören. Vielen Dank.
So, sehr gut. Und jetzt kommen wir, also wie gesagt, wenn ihr noch Fragen habt, ähnlich wie Robin, könnt ihr gerne noch anrufen, 0331 70 97 110. Und wir wollen jetzt aber mal die andere Seite betrachten. Ausgangspunkt für die andere Seite ist sozusagen die öffentliche Wahrnehmung des Problems Biometrie und Fingerabdrücke. Wir haben schon gehört, 2004 hat der Chaos Computer Club zum ersten Mal gezeigt, wie einfach es ist, einen Fingerabdruckscanner zu überlisten. Und es ist dieses Jahr, 2013, hat es das am Wahlabend auf die Titelseiten einiger Online-Zeitungen gebracht. Und da fragt man sich natürlich sozusagen, okay, das sind jetzt neun Jahre. Es hat neun Jahre gedauert. Und es hat anscheinend ein Lifestyleprodukt gebraucht.
Das ist nicht ganz richtig.
Starbucks und Konz, bitte, lasst mich doch noch kurz die Einladung machen, weil das ist die öffentliche Wahrnehmung. Die öffentliche Wahrnehmung ist genau das. Ich muss hier gleich mal jemanden pelpen. Frau Doktor Kurz, vielen Dank, dass Sie das gesagt haben.
Du hast doch den Regel an der Hand.
Also der Punkt ist sozusagen, dass in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung ist tatsächlich die Biometrie jetzt erst eine große Tatsache. Und das ist sozusagen mit dem iPhone, weil es ein so wichtiges Lifestyleprodukt ist. Aber, und das haben die beiden mir schon vorher erzählt, der Anfang, dass das Presseinteresse so groß war, begann schon zu sagen, bevor der Hack überhaupt bekannt war, nämlich mit, ist Touch ID hacked yet?
Darauf wollte ich gar nicht hin. Du möchtest dich ausreden. Was ich nämlich sagen wollte, also es war tatsächlich gerade in Deutschland schon mal relativ groß in der Presse und zwar damals zu Schäuble-Zeiten. Also als wir den Schäuble-Fingerabdruck. Und das war durchaus, also jetzt ist es international natürlich viel, viel größer. Aber für Deutschland, würde ich sagen, war es auf jeden Fall zu der Zeit. Das war vor drei Jahren oder so was.
Na, es war schon mal ein Nachrichtenthema, aber sozusagen aber so ein Thema, wo man, also weißt du, so Atomwaffen sind halt auch ein Nachrichtenthema. Das interessiert jeden. Aber jetzt die persönliche Betroffenheit ist nicht so da. Und jetzt ist es halt einfach so, dass das jetzt so klar wird und ich habe auch das Gefühl, dass mehr in diese Richtung berichtet wird, dass das ein Problem ist, das tatsächlich jeden Einzelnen jetzt betrifft. Das ist halt das andere. Klar, als wir damals den Schäuble-Fingerabdruck in der Datenschleuder ausgeliefert haben, da war das sozusagen ein News-Thema.
Nee, ich würd's eigentlich dennoch nicht unterschreiben. Weil ich glaube, dass damals die Debatte, wir müssen uns ja mal erinnern, 2005 im November kamen die ersten Reisepässe, die die Biometrie drin hatten. Und 2007 in der nächsten Stufe und dann 2011 der Ausweis. Es war schon so, dass die Biometrie jeden betroffen hat. Und der Schäuble-Abdruck, wo wir ja auch nur erklärt haben, dass das als Sicherheitstechnik eigentlich nicht gut geeignet ist und warum, der landete auf der, ich darf das mal, wenn ich mich daran erinnere... Ja, Bild. Also in deutschen Verhältnissen war das schon, und da gab es auch eine Menge Hype und Fernsehsendungen, aber wir haben jetzt halt eine internationale Dimension. Und das betrifft aber im Grunde weniger Leute. Weil also ein Ausweis oder Pass hat jeder, das ist ja quasi dann zwangsweise, aber ein iPhone hat nun nicht jeder. Insofern ist das schon eine ausgesuchte Gruppe von Gadget-Lovern, die auch gerade sich so für die Einführung interessieren.
Deutlich weniger problematische Anwendung auch. Also war halt nicht der Staat tatsächlich die Daten, sondern halt...
Das ist einfach eine andere Gruppe, die man jetzt anspricht, aber nicht unbedingt eine kleinere. Wir haben also so ein bisschen, ich glaube, dass es so dicke kommt, haben wir auch nicht vermutet. Aber so ganz überrascht hat es uns natürlich auch nicht. Also war natürlich Apple gerade so als Technologievorreiter, wie sie sich ja nach wie vor auch inszenieren, ein hoher Interesse hat, gerade so bei den Technikseiten, die darüber berichten. Und dann gab es eben, was du eben ansprachst.
Also Apple ist auf jeden Fall nicht schuld, dass es so gut in der Presse war, weil Apple, wie so oft bei Problemen mit Apple-Produkten schweigt, ist einfach tot. Also ich hab so viele Artikel in den letzten paar Tagen gelesen, wo immer unten drunter stand, wir haben irgendwie Apple nach Kommentaren gefragt, aber keine Antwort bisher erhalten.
Genau.
Und das ist einfach... Und da ist die Strategie, sie werden es jetzt irgendwie zwei Wochen aussitzen und weiter ihre Telefone verkaufen, als wäre nichts gewesen, Leute werden es trotzdem benutzen. Aber also warum es tatsächlich so stark in der Presse, also auch in der US-amerikanischen Presse gelandet ist, ist dieses Is-Touch-ID Hacked Yet. Das war halt irgendwie tatsächlich von zwei Security-Forschern, irgendwie aus Amerika aufgemachtes, so ein Bounty-Hunt. Also sie haben tatsächlich gesagt, da kommt dieses Produkt raus und wir glauben, dass es sicher ist, aber wir wollen mal irgendwie die Hacker-Gemeinde oder wen auch immer mal ein bisschen Anreiz vermitteln, dass da genauer aufgeguckt wird. Und sie haben halt gesagt, oder der erste hat gesagt, ich spende 500 Dollar für den ersten, der es irgendwie hackt. Hat das irgendwie in seinem Blog geschrieben, hat irgendwie ein bisschen rumgetwittert. Und dann sind halt tatsächlich innerhalb von kürzester Zeit mehrere tausend Dollar plus mehrere Flaschen gute Whisky und ein Sexheft und ein iPhone 5S zu bekommen.
Und eine Patent-Application, also eine Patentanmeldung, die ja in den USA auch nicht gerade billig ist.
Genau, es gab halt einen, der halt tatsächlich den Hack dann wirklich hätte patentieren lassen wollen. Ich hab auch kurz mit dem irgendwie getwittert und meinte irgendwie, also er hat es mir angeboten, ich hab gesagt, wir haben hier Sachen verwendet, die halt zehn Jahre bekannt sind, das ist total sinnlos, da einfach etwas zu machen. Also noch dazu, wo ich halt eh nicht so patentbeflissen bin oder begeistert von daher, also das ist halt schon mal weg gewesen. Aber sind tatsächlich wirklich, also ich hab vor noch mal nachgefragt, gut dreieinhalbtausend Euro bisher irgendwie eingegangen. Also die tatsächlich schon überwiesen wurden. Plus noch mal so was wie zehn bis 15 Bitcoins, was irgendwie auch noch mal anderthalbtausend Euro sind. Also da ist halt schon tatsächlich ganz schön viel Geld zusammengekommen und die Leute haben es tatsächlich dann auch überwiesen. Also ich meine, es war so, sie haben gesagt, dass sie es tun, aber es heißt ja dann noch nicht, dass tatsächlich irgendwie auch dann gespendet wird. Aber da ist durchaus ein bisschen Geld reingekommen.
Jetzt musst du aber natürlich auch sagen, dass du es nicht behältst.
Ja, also ich hab das Geld ganz altruistisch der Raumfahrtagentur gespendet. Das ist ein Spin-off vom CCC Berlin.
Also ein Hacker-Space.
Also ein Hacker-Space, also so ein Hacker- und Makerspace. Und die haben das auf jeden Fall nötiger und waren auch alle sehr glücklich.
Und haben ja auch ihren Anteil an dem Hack in gewisser Weise.
Genau, also ich hab auch teilweise da irgendwie dort gefilmt und irgendwie mit Leuten von dort natürlich drüber geredet.
Und zerforscht.
Auf jeden Fall gibt's da auch noch weitere Hacks, die man da irgendwie machen kann. Von daher geht das Geld schon in die richtigen Kanäle.
Aber eigentlich wollten wir darüber sprechen, warum ist Saturday Hacked jetzt sozusagen das Pressinteresse angestachelt hat.
Also es hat's auf jeden Fall halt im Vorfeld. Also normalerweise irgendwie hast du die Apple, wie heißen die diese, wir springen auf der Bühne rum.
Die Apple springen auf der Bühne rum?
Die Apple-Manager, wie heißt denn das? Keynotes, Keynotes, genau. Diese Keynote, die halt irgendwie so Produkte neu vorstellt und wo halt irgendwie dann zwei Tage ganz großer Hype ist. Aber das war halt schon im August oder wann auch immer. Und dann ist es eigentlich halt irgendwie erstmal abgeappt. Und dann wär's halt normalerweise irgendwie am Tag der Auslieferung. Also praktisch am Freitag wär's dann wieder in der Presse gewesen, das Thema. Und die haben ungefähr so zwei Wochen vorletzten Freitag halt diese Challenge aufgemacht, diese Bounty-Hand. Und das tatsächlich, also gerade in den USA, war das halt sehr groß in der Presse, weil es halt einfach irgendwie Aufmerksamkeit hat. Also halt jeder hat übers iPhone geredet, aber keiner über den Fingerabdruck oder über die Unsicherheiten. Und halt diese, wir haben hier Geld geboten für den Ersten, der es schafft. Und halt immer wieder dann kam halt irgendwie, da hat noch jemand was gespendet und da kommen jetzt irgendwie 10.000 Euro dazu. Dann gab es auch noch den Fall, dass halt der eine Großspender sich im Nachhinein als irgendwie Fake rausgestellt hat. Der hat halt versucht diese Kampagne zu übernehmen und für seine Firma zu werben. Das heißt, es ist halt tatsächlich relativ groß da irgendwie auch durch die Techpresse gegangen. Und hat das Thema wirklich halt über zwei Wochen bis zum Release irgendwie einfach am Kochen gehalten.
Ja, aber natürlich ist das nicht der Antrieb. Also der Antrieb, also von unserer Seite ist natürlich irgendwie immer schon gewesen, sind die Behauptungen, die bei dieser ganzen Werbe und dieser ganzen Marketing Kampagne, die ja so gebracht werden, sind die wahr? Kann man das mit der Technik belegen oder falsifizieren? Und dann natürlich auch, also reine technische Interesse zu gucken, haben die da wirklich einen neuen coolen Shiny Sensor hingebaut oder ist das doch bloß wieder ein alter Wagen in neuen Schläuchen?
Für uns war das tatsächlich irgendwie total irrelevant. Und als am Sonntag vieles irgendwie rausgebracht haben, hab ich natürlich irgendwie auch Kontakt mit denen aufgenommen. Also es war auch so der Grund, warum wir das jetzt irgendwie, wir machen das jetzt und zeigen das Video. Also das erste Video, was ich gezeigt hab, war tatsächlich noch nicht das komplette. Das heißt, man hat nicht gesehen, dass ich den Fingerabdruck vom Glas abgenommen hab. Ich hab's denen halt gesagt, dass es so ist und ich das Video irgendwann nachliefere, wenn ich irgendwie mal ein bisschen Ruhe gefunden hab und das Video erst mal machen kann. Und halt da kamen viel so Gespräche zustande, die halt irgendwie meinten, ja, sie haben es aber nicht gezeigt, deswegen habt ihr nicht gewonnen. Also die Seite war auch irgendwie erst, wurde nicht gehackt. Dann maybe und haben dann irgendwann erst irgendwie später auf yes geswitcht. Und es hat mich zwischenzeitlich, ich war irgendwie richtig dolch, denke ich, weil sie hat alle davon geredet haben, du musstest uns aber beweisen, weil sonst kriegst du das Geld nicht. Und ich war so, ey Jungs, ich hab das irgendwie nicht wegen des Geldes gemacht. Ich hab's gemacht, weil es einfach irgendwie ein cooler Hack ist und lasst mich doch irgendwie in Ruhe mit dem Geld.
Zurück zur Presse.
Na, also der Aspekt, den du vorhin so erwähnt hast, dass es natürlich ein Lifestyleprodukt ist und dass es doch wahrscheinlich das erste Konsumentengerät ist, was in dieser Anzahl biometrische Sensoren für so Lifestyleprodukte anbietet, ist natürlich schon wichtig. Und auch diese Vorreiterrolle von Apple in puncto Art, wie man den Benutzer leitet, ich glaube, das hat damit schon zu tun. Und die Tatsache, dass es gleichzeitig auf mehreren Kontinenten eben zum Verkauf angeboten wurde, das ist schon so eine Melange. Und außerdem muss auch sagen, die erste Berichterstattung, die so vor allen Dingen in den USA und dann in Kanada war, die war so ein bisschen verkürzt. Muss ich schon sagen. Ja, später hat eigentlich die so ein bisschen seriösere Tech-Presse da genauere Artikel gebracht und auch so ein bisschen die Technik erklärt. Es war halt erst so ein bisschen, Hacker haben Apple zerlegt und gehackt. Später wurde dann so ein bisschen genauer.
Also es war ja auch so, dass tatsächlich unsere erste Pressemeldung, also von Sonntagabend, irgendwie halt noch auf die Fakten von Samstag basierend, also wir haben irgendwie noch von Abfotografieren und von Folien zum Hacken irgendwie berichtet.
Stimmt ja auch, aber letztlich ist also der wirklich gut funktionierende Hack, den man nachmachen sollte, wenn man es probieren will, der ist halt erst später erläutert worden.
Ich glaube das Wichtige tatsächlich für die Presse war auch einfach das Video zu sehen, wie es gemacht wurde. Und halt irgendwie nur so das Video mit irgendwie da so ein Typ oder so ein Finger, so eine Hand zu sehen, die halt irgendwie einmal sich auf den Finger legt, eine Trappe auf dem anderen Finger legt und rauftrückt. Das ist halt irgendwie nichts, was man jetzt halt toll ausschlachten kann.
Aber trotzdem ist ja natürlich die spannende Frage. Also es gibt ja zum Beispiel, wer hat schon Fingerabdrucks in seinen Laptops? Lenovo?
Ja, die Lenovo hat gibt ein paar mehr.
Aber Lenovo ist ja so eine Marke, die ist auch so als Business Laptop verschrieben. Das heißt, das wird im wichtigen Bereich genutzt. Und da wäre doch genau dasselbe möglich gewesen. Also was ist jetzt sozusagen, warum ist es genau das jetzt?
Ich glaube es ist tatsächlich Apple. Also weil Apple halt schon so ein, irgendwie alle geifern drauf, wenn halt neue Apple-Produkte, also gerade wenn diese Keynote ist, also ich kenne es ja auch von ein paar Leuten so aus dem Club, die dann irgendwie gemeinsam vor den Notebooks sitzen und irgendwie sich freuen, was jetzt irgendwie neu in iOS 7 ist.
Ja, Apple hat halt eine besonders loyaler Anhängerschaft. Sich auch in Ruhe verarbeitet, glaube ich, durch viele innovative Produkte. Also wir brauchen ja wohl ein iPod, iPad und so. Aber ich glaube dazu kommt noch so ein Element. Also mein Eindruck ist so, diese starke Werbung, wenn man sich jetzt mal ansieht, wie sie präsentiert haben, hat glaube ich auch damit zu tun. Das wurde eben als zentrale Feature an diesem neuen... Es gibt noch einen dritten Aspekt, der der Mobiltelefonmarkt, gerade bei Smartphones, ist halt derzeit einfach sehr umkämpft. Wenn man sich so sammelsungen, dann die Nokia-Berichterstattung, Blackberry, da ist halt gerade, da gucken halt alle drauf, weil das eben auch ein wichtiger ähm, also zum Beispiel ein Unternehmen, ein wichtiger finanzieller Marktanteil ist.
Bei den Notebook war es halt so, da guckt man halt eher drauf, oh der hat eine große Platte drinnen, der hat einen schnellen Prozessor drinnen. Bei dem iPhone, jetzt bei dem iPhone 5S, war es halt einfach so gewesen, das ist das zentrale Feature von diesem neuen Telefon, was irgendwie halt alle, wo alle drauf anspringen.
Tatsächlich gab es ja auch einen Knick im Aktienkurs, wo wir doch so ein bisschen gefeixt haben, der sehr sichtbar ist.
Meint ihr, dass es damit zu tun hat?
Zumindest hat die Presse das so berichtet. Also natürlich, also die Angst ist sicherlich schon da, dass wenn man an einem Produkt, was man gerade mit hohem Aufwand weltweit launst und natürlich auch verkaufen will und wo auch die Wirtschaftspresse natürlich guckt, wie verkauft sich in den ersten Tagen eine Rolle spielt, wenn da plötzlich ein zentrales Feature stark kritisiert wird. Aber letztlich an den Verkaufen, das kann man ja sehen, er hat kaum, also da sieht man keinen Effekt und das ist glaube ich auch nicht unbedingt angemessen, weil schon diese Convenience, diese Bequemlichkeit beim Benutzen im Vordergrund steht und nicht so sehr die Sicherheit und wir wollten ja eigentlich auch auf grundsätzliche Probleme hinweisen und nicht unbedingt das Produkt an sich matig machen, sondern auf diese falsche Sicherheitsversprechen hinweisen.
Also von uns aus ging es auch gar nicht und im Hype ging es darauf, irgendwie wir haben es halt gemacht, weil es irgendwie da war, weil man es machen konnte und haben natürlich die Gelegenheit genutzt, halt nochmal auf die grundsätzlichen Probleme von Bimetrie hinzuweisen. Was durchaus jetzt bei Smartphones halt, also ich halte es schon für einen wichtigen Faktor, weil halt Smartphones einfach deutlich wichtiger im zukünftigen Leben sein werden. Also die nehmen halt so den Computer langsam laufen in den Rang ab. Das heißt, du hast halt wirklich sehr wichtige Daten auch auf deinem Telefon gespeichert und schützt es im Zweifelsfall wirklich entweder gar nicht. Also es hat ja Apple auch gesagt, dass was 40% der Apple Benutzer gar keinen Passcode haben. Für die ist natürlich ein Fingerabdruck halt schon mal einen Schritt in die richtige Richtung. Aber man muss sich einfach mal vor Augen führen, was dort für wichtige Daten auf den Telefon drauf sind. Und die schützt man mit halt so einem Merkmal, was halt tatsächlich überall hinterlassen wird. Das ist halt schon deutlich kritisch.
Das möchte ich an dieser Stelle mal festhalten. Also du sagst tatsächlich sozusagen, ihr wolltet zwar zeigen, dass das angreifbar ist, aber es ist besser als gar nicht zu sichern.
Also man muss sich auf jeden Fall, also wenn man halt gar nicht sichert, dann weiß man, dass es gar nicht gesichert ist. Wenn man halt Apple mit ihrer Werbung vertraut hätte, denkt man, oh das ist total hochsicher. Das heißt irgendwie falsche Sicherheit ist natürlich auch nicht gut. Aber so aus Angreifersicht ist natürlich alles, was du halt machen musst. Ich meine, der Prozess ist zwar jetzt durchaus einfach, aber ich meine, du musst halt schon Aufwand treiben, um ihn durchzuführen. Anders als halt gar kein Passcode zu haben, ist es halt schon zusätzlicher Aufwand. Das heißt irgendwie ist es durchaus für die Leute sicherer, wenn sie halt, statt gar kein Passcode zu haben, einen Fingerabdruck benutzen.
Das ist eine sehr interessante Stelle gerade, weil wenn man die Diskussion in der Öffentlichkeit verfolgt, ist es ja oft so, dass es die zwei Lager gibt, wo die einen halt sagen so, was? Nein, Fingerabdruck ist doch das Haarl Super und die Rettung der Welt und die anderen sagen so, nein, Fingerabdruck ist für gar nichts zu gebrauchen und ich möchte hier auch mal auf die reflektierten Zwischentöne achten. Glaubt ihr denn, dass die, dass tatsächlich das größere Ziel sind mit Biometrie zu beschäftigen, jetzt auch kommen wird durch diese News oder glaubt ihr, dass es jetzt sozusagen so eine Hype News und dann in zwei Wochen ist wieder alles vorbei und beim nächsten großen Gerät muss man dann nochmal von vorne anfangen zu erklären, was Fingerabdrücke eigentlich bedeuten.
Na, ich denke schon, dass grundsätzliche Zweifel an der Biometrie so als Sicherheitstechnik, die sind sicherlich gepflanzt. Die sind natürlich auch schon vorher gepflanzt worden.
Also ich glaube tatsächlich, dass der Hacks selber gar nicht so sehr zur kritischen Betrachtungsweise beigetragen hat, sondern tatsächlich eher so dieser Snowden NSA schickt Apple die Finger, drückt direkt an die NSA Vermutungen.
Sollte man die irgendwo hinterlegen.
Also das ist tatsächlich halt deutlich wichtiger in dem Fall.
Und dann, also wir hatten in der Pressemitteilung nochmal so einen Hinweis, dass man natürlich im Vergleich mit dem Passwort sehr viel leichter gezwungen sein kann, diese biometrische Merkmal abzugeben. Trägt man halt bei sich.
Also das war in Amerika gerade irgendwie, was ist das, First Amendment oder so was? Also dass du halt das Recht hast, dich nicht selbst zu belasten, also das gilt ja auch in Deutschland, und halt beim Passcode, also du kannst halt niemanden zwingen, den Passcode einzugeben, du kannst immer behaupten, ich hab ihn vergessen und sie können dir halt nicht das Gegenteil beweisen. Wohingegen halt deinen Finger irgendwie zu nehmen und das Telefon ranzuhalten, irgendwie da kann man halt nicht wirklich viel gegen tun. Also da gibt's so ein cooles Bild von so einem Mädchen, dass irgendwie das Telefon irgendwie von ihrem Dad irgendwie an den Finger hält, während er schläft, das ist irgendwie wirklich sehr süß. Und das zeigt halt wirklich sehr, sehr gut die Problematik. Und das ist halt viel schlimmer, als es kann gehackt werden und tatsächlich so es gibt halt keine Möglichkeit zu verhindern, dass es jemand gegen dich verwendet.
Na und du kannst das auch nicht austauschen. Also ich meine, dein Finger abdruckklebt an dir, das ist ein Körpermerkmal, wäre nur natürlich ein Passcode, wenn du ihn außerhalb jemand anderes bekannt gibst oder auch gerne möchtest, weil du ihm vielleicht aus irgendeinem Grund so ein Telefon mal geben musst. Du kannst das nicht austauschen. Und du hast, weil du einfach ein Mensch bist und Dinge anfasst, natürlich dauernd diese Latenzabdrücke, die du an Türen, Fenstern, Gläsern, Tassen, das ist nun mal so. Und dann auch noch direkt auf dem iPhone, wo du ja eben nur mal drauftatscht und da sind die halt auch zu Dutzenden drauf. Also das ist im Prinzip eine doofe Idee. Wir raten definitiv dazu, ein Passwort zu nehmen.
Jetzt ist ja, ich hab einen Blogartikel gelesen, hat jemand vorgeschlagen, dass man das so zweiteilig macht, also dass man sozusagen fürs einfache Freischalten und Benutzen des Telefons den Fingerabdruck nimmt, weil es ist halt einfach super bequem. Und dann aber für alles, was irgendwie mit Änderungen zu tun hat oder man kann es vielleicht auch einstellen, da wird dann doch ein Passcode verwendet. Haltet ihr sowas für gut oder sagt ihr, Fingerabdruck ist einfach so doof, dass man sie lieber besser gar nicht benutzen sollte.
Wie gesagt, also hab ich ja vorhin schon mal angedeutet, es hängt halt davon ab, was für Daten tatsächlich geschützt werden damit. Und ich geh davon aus, dass auf dem Telefon heutzutage so viele wirklich wichtige persönliche Daten drauf sind, dass ich dem Fingerabdruck einfach nicht anvertrauen würde.
Okay, also Fingerabdruck ist für euch sowas, wenn man irgendwie im Badeboiler die Wassertemperatur für alle Familienmitglieder abspeichert, dann kann man das gerne per Fingerabdruck machen. Also so Convenience-Sachen. Aber sobald es um wirklich persönliche Daten geht, ist ein Fingerabdruck eigentlich immer eine schlechte Idee.
Naja, immer noch voraussetzt, man benutzt ein Passwort. Für die Leute, die das vorher gar nicht gesichert haben, die sollen mal schön ihr Passwort...
Die sollen auch ein Passwort benutzen. Ich mein, jeder wird sich einen scheiß vierstelligen Code merken können.
Inwiefern ist denn eigentlich ein vierstelliger Code wirklich sicherer als ein Fingerabdruck?
Den lässt du halt nirgendwo. Also du kannst auf jeden Fall tatsächlich darauf aufpassen, dass halt keiner den weiß. Das heißt irgendwie, da muss man entweder dich foltern, um ihn rauszufinden oder was auch immer tun. Beim Fingerabdruck kannst du es halt einfach nicht, also definitiv nicht verhindern. Es gibt halt so Tipps wie benutzen, den hinterlässt du nirgendwo. Aber wenn du halt tatsächlich einer Person, also auf dieses Telefon von einer Person gezielt irgendwie Angriffe fahren willst, dann findest du Möglichkeiten, den Fingerabdruck zu bekommen. Du kannst auch Fotos von Fingerabdrücken nehmen und so weiter. Also es geht auf jeden Fall alles.
Ich möchte bei dieser Gelegenheit darauf hinweisen, dass auch andere hautähnliche Körperteile für diesen Sensor benutzbar sind.
Ich möchte das an dieser Stelle nicht weiter ausführen und auf die nächste halbe Stunde verweisen, wo wir nochmal ein bisschen über das breitere Thema Biometrie reden werden. Jetzt gibt es erstmal die Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr. Dann sind wir gleich wieder für euch da. Dann könnt ihr, wenn ihr Fragen habt, auch gerne nochmal anrufen unter 033 177 97 110.
Nach drei Jahren melden sie sich mit ihrem dritten Studioalbum zurück. Und zwar live und am 3.
Fritz präsentiert.
MGMT nach drei Jahren mit ihrem 3. Album live und am 3.
Oktober.
Präsentiert von Fritz.
Immer gute neue Musik.
Mit Mario Barsch.
In der CDU-Führung werden Steuererhöhungen als Angebot an einen künftigen Koalitionspartner ausgeschlossen. Generalsekretär Gröhe stellte klar, dass der Spitzensteuersatz nicht verhandelbar sei. Berichte, wonach er seine Erhöhung, eine Erhöhung des Steuersatzes als mögliches Zugeständnis an SPD und Grüne genannt habe, seien falsch. Ähnlich äußerte sich auch Unionsfraktionschef Kauder. Steuererhöhungen seien aus gutem Grund im Regierungsprogramm von CDU und CSU nicht vorgesehen. Darin werde sich auch nichts ändern. Ein erhöhter Spitzensteuersatz für besser Verdienende war ein zentrales Wahlkampfthema von SPD und Grünen. In der EU müssen Bahngesellschaften ihre Fahrgäste bei größeren Verspätungen auch dann entschädigen, wenn höhere Gewalt der Grund ist. Der Europäische Gerichtshof in Luxemburg entschied, dass die Entschädigung nicht unter Verweis auf Ereignisse wie Unwetter, Erdrutsche oder Streiks verweigert werden darf. Reisende haben demnach je nach Verspätung Anspruch darauf, dass der Fahrpreis bis zu 50% erstattet werden kann. Die Deutsche Bahn begrüßte die Luxemburger Entscheidung. Damit sei Rechtssicherheit geschaffen worden, hieß es. Man werde das Urteil unverzüglich umsetzen. Die Negativschlagzeilen rund um die Fußball-WM 2022 in Katar reißen nicht ab. Laut Recherchen der englischen Tageszeitung Guardian sind zwischen Juni und August insgesamt 44 nepalesische Gastarbeiter auf den WM-Baustellen wegen Herzversagens oder bei Arbeitsunfällen gestorben. Die vielen Todesfälle gingen vor allem auf die katastrophalen Bedingungen zurück, wie Zwangsarbeit bei Temperaturen von 50 Grad, die Verweigerung von Trinkwasser und die unhygienischen Bedingungen in den überfüllten Unterkünften. Der Weltfußballverband FIFA kündigte an, die Verantwortlichen in Katar zu kontaktieren. Der ehemalige Präsident des westafrikanischen Landes Liberia, Taylor, ist endgültig zu 50 Jahren Haft verurteilt worden. Ein UN-Sondertribunal sah es als erwiesen an, dass Taylor Rebellen im Nachbarland Sierra Leone zu Kriegsverbrechen angestiftet und unterstützt hat. Konkret geht es um tausendfachen Mord, Folter und Vergewaltigung. Taylor hatte die Rebellen von 1998 bis 2001 mit Waffen beliefert und dafür Diamanten bekommen. Die aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin Köpenick 4, in Charlottenburg 7 Grad. Cottbus meldet 5, Falkensee, Bad Freienwalde und Wiesenburg melden 6 Grad. Heute Nacht ist es meist locker bewölkt und trocken, die Temperaturen sinken auf 5 bis 1 Grad. Am Tag ist es dann meist heiter und sonnig, nur im Norden kann es auch mal einen Schauer geben, bei maximal 12 bis 15 Grad. Stadtverkehr Berlin A 100, Stadtring Richtung Süden zwischen Spandauer Damm und Messe Damm stockt es derzeit. Steglitz, der Abzweig Steglitz, ist zwischen Schildhornstraße und Mecklenburgische Straße gesperrt. Dort gibt es Straßenschäden. Tiergarten, wegen der Vorbereitung zum Berlin-Marathon am Wochenende ist die Straße des 17. Juni zwischen Lietzer Grabinstraße und Brandenburger Tor gesperrt. Ab 6 Uhr früh wird die Vollspörung bis zum großen Stern erweitert. Nach Brandenburg B 5 nauen Richtung Küritz, zwischen dem Kreisverkehr Briesen und dem Kreisverkehr Friesak gab es einen Unfall, die rechte Spur ist gesperrt. Und noch zur S-Bahn. Zwischen Marienfelde und Priesterweg gibt es bis Betriebsschluss Ersatzverkehr mit Bussen. Ab 4 Uhr früh werden die Züge der S1 von und nach Oranienburg ab Bornholmer Straße über Blankenburg nach Hohen Neuen Dorf umgeleitet. Wo es geht, gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBW. Heute Chaosradio im Blue Moon an der Moderation Markus Richter und begrüßt herzlich noch mal seine Gäste Starbuck und Frau Doktor Constanze Kurz. Hallo und guten Abend. Es geht um einen Fingerabdruck. Es geht um mehrere Fingerabdrücke. Es geht um Fingerabdruckscanner, die man hacken kann und um Biometrie im Allgemeinen. Das jetzt. Wir haben in der ersten Stunde geklärt, wie es technisch geht, dass man Fingerabdrücke nachbildet und somit einen Fingerabdruckscanner überlistet. In der letzten halben Stunde haben wir ein bisschen über die Presse, über den Widerhall in der Gesellschaft geredet und wollen jetzt noch mal generell ein bisschen über Biometrie reden, weil dieses neue Lifestyleprodukt, was jetzt für die große Aufregung gesorgt hat, ist ja nicht das Einzige. Biometrie beschäftigt uns ja auch in anderen Bereichen und am ehesten hat man es wohl gehört, bei Personalausweis und Reisepass, wo die ja mit reinkommen, das wurde ja auch ab und zu schon mal angesprochen. Wie ist denn da jetzt der Stand gerade?
Also ich denke, über die letzten Jahre hat uns mehr so diese staatliche Biometrie sammeln beschäftigt. Einfach weil in vielen Ländern der Welt, ist ja nicht nur in Deutschland so, insbesondere für die Reisepässe, sowohl biometrische Gesichtsbild wie auch Fingerabdrücke gesammelt werden. Und auch weil in den letzten vier Jahren, drei, vier Jahren, viele Länder angefangen haben an Flughäfen die Leute zu zwingen, unabhängig von ihrem Reisepass Fingerabdrücke und auch Gesichtsbilder dort abzugeben. Da sind ja riesengroße, also millionenfache Datenbanken entstanden, besonders in den USA, aber nicht nur. In Deutschland war das, glaube ich, nicht ganz unumstritten. Also gab zumindest überhaupt eine Diskussion, sowohl als es so losging. Wir haben 2003 und 2004 schon das erste Mal damals auch mit anderen Organisationen zusammen gewarnt davor. Aber es ist ja letztlich auch eine Entscheidung gewesen, die in allen europäischen Ländern durchgezogen wurde und dann jetzt zuletzt, also es zog sich über ein paar Jahre, 2011 fing das an, dann auch am Ausweis und nicht nur am Ausweis, sondern auch an diesem Aufenthaltstitel. Also die Leute, die jetzt keine deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft haben, sondern eben nur dauerhaft in Deutschland leben, die kriegen eben auch so einen Biometrieausweis. Und da sind viele Aspekte. Wir haben schon immer auch die Sicherheit bekrittelt, aber auch qualitative Fragen, also wie gut sind eigentlich diese Sensoren? Macht es eigentlich wirklich Sinn? Ist das eigentlich eine Sicherheitstechnik? Dann aber auch die Diskriminierung. Also da gibt es eben nur mal Menschen, die können kein neutrales Gesichtsbild aufnehmen oder die haben keine Finger. Also da sind ja Probleme. Oder sie sind insbesondere mit Alter überschritten. Dann werden die Fingerabdrücke zum Beispiel qualitativ sehr viel schlechter. Warum wird das auch bei Kindern gemacht? Also da gibt es einfach sehr viele Probleme, die wir von Anfang an besprochen haben. Und dazu kam dann zwischendurch noch unsere Aktion mit dem damaligen Innenminister, wo wir den Fingerabdruck geklaut haben, um das auch nochmal öffentlich zu machen. Aber letztlich war auch sicherlich das industrielle und Wirtschaftsinteresse an dieser Technik unglaublich groß. Denn der Staat war da so ein bisschen der Initiator, dass es jetzt ein paar Jahre später in diesen Konsumentenmarkt übergeht. Und wiederum, genau wie im Prinzip früher als sogenannte Sicherheitstechnik verkauft wird, von der wir meinen, dass dort eigentlich jetzt nicht die Meere, ein Placebo, was einem da versprochen wird. Für die Bequemlichkeit mag das Hinkommen, für die Sicherheit kommt das nicht hin.
Trotzdem wird es sozusagen gefordert für Reisepässe und auch für Personalausweise. Und da hat Mona eine Frage. Hallo Mona.
Hallo.
Ich möchte mal fragen, wie das ist. Kann ich das eigentlich irgendwie umgehen? Nein, ich möchte eigentlich nicht meinen Fingerabdruck abgeben. Ich finde das eine Unverschämtheit und ich möchte es einfach nicht. Wenn ich jetzt mal auf irgendwann meinen Personalausweis beantragen muss, kann ich das irgendwie umgehen, gehen?
Also beim Personalausweis ist das tatsächlich optional. Das heißt, du kannst sagen, du möchtest den Fingerabdruck nicht abgeben. Anders ist das beim Reisepass.
Lass dich aber nicht bequatschen. Also wir haben auch gelernt, dass auf dem Melderempter bei dem Ausweisen teilweise dann so getan wird, als wenn man das müsste. Das muss man nicht. Jetzt steht natürlich auch so eine Ausweisverordnung. Man kann einfach nein sagen.
Also bei Ausweisen hast du tatsächlich die Wahl, ob du es machen willst oder nicht. Falls du irgendwann mal einen Pass brauchst, stehst du leider nicht mehr vor der Wahl, sondern da ist es tatsächlich zwangsweise verordnet.
Aber ich möchte einfach keinen Fingerabdruck abgeben und dann nehme ich einfach keinen Reisepass. Aber nur bei so einer Ausweise darf man mit Nein sagen.
Also natürlich geben wir auch Tipps und Hinweise, wie man drumherum kommt, im Meldeamt seinen Fingerabdruck abzugeben. Aber jetzt muss ich mal den Moderator angucken, ob wir das im Radio sagen dürfen.
Hier geht es ja tatsächlich. So lange du nur einen Personalsweis brauchst, kannst du einfach sagen nein und musst das auch nicht tun. Für den Reisepass ist das irgendwie noch mal was anderes. Falls du irgendwann mal in die verzweifelte Lage kommst, dann melde dich einfach noch mal bei uns. Dann können wir dir da auch helfen, dass es dann ein bisschen kommt.
Biometri-EdCCC.de ist da die Adresse. Da machen wir das auch sehr konkret. Wir haben da natürlich über die Jahre jetzt einige Versuche gestartet.
Jetzt bin ich ja nach der Ankündigung tatsächlich selber neugierig. Aber wenn ihr jetzt schon von alleine sagt, dass man das möglicherweise nicht erzählen kann.
Ich hab damit kein Problem. Ich weiß noch nicht. Also ich wollte dich nur angucken und dein Nicken sehen vorher.
Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht genau, worum es sich handelt. Wollt ihr irgendwie, dass die Leute sich die Finger in den Eierschneider halten oder was?
Würde ich nicht empfehlen. Wäre natürlich möglich, wenn man sich alle fünf, nein, man nimmt nur von vier Fingern die Abdrücke. Also die kleinen Finger. Ich möchte das einfach, einfach. Na ja gut, aber mit der Argumentation wirst du natürlich auf den Mädeamt dann nicht weiterkommen. Du musst schon, also die sind dir auf den Mädeamt dann auch verpflichtet. Dann gibt es ja noch einen Passform. Aber nicht bei meinem Personalausweis.
Solange du nur einen Personalausweis haben willst, bist du sicher und kannst erst mal beruhigt weiterschlafen.
Ja, aber beim Reisebad dann melde ich mich mal auf der Seite da.
Genau.
ccc.de Genau, einfach noch Mehl treiben. So, das war die Mona. Oder wie kannst du ja auch anders formulieren, gibt es z.B. bestimmte Berufsgruppen, die keine Fingerabdrücker haben?
ZB auch, nö, also Leute, die viel mit Chemikalien oder mit z.B. auch Bergsteiger, also Kletterer sind auch sehr ungeeignet für die Abgabe von Fingerabdrücken. Aber das ist dann tatsächlich schon was Spezielleres. Also was z.B. sehr gut hilft, ist Sekundenkleber auf die Finger zu machen und sie damit halt nicht mehr auslesbar zu machen.
Man füllt damit quasi die Rillen. Von denen wir vorhin schon sprachen.
Man muss natürlich eine gute Ausrede haben. Normalerweise, wenn man sagt, man arbeitet viel mit Chemikalien, dann kommt man in der Regel drum rum. Das heißt, dann haben sie irgendwann den Haken, der hat keine Finger bzw. keine Fingerabdrücke.
Den gibt es natürlich, weil ja Menschen keine Finger haben.
Man muss sich dann schon ausreichend doof stellen, aber es geht.
Wenn ich jetzt hinkomme und sage, Obst, ich bin gerade im Sekundenkleber gefallen.
Wenn man den Sekundenkleber aufträgt, dann ist das nicht unmittelbar sichtbar. Also es sieht so ein bisschen aus, als wenn man vielleicht, wie manche, ich weiß nicht, ob du kennst, Frisöre haben manchmal so eine Finger, wo man einfach merkt, die haben sehr viel mit ätzenden Materialien zu tun. So sieht es so ein bisschen so aus. Und auf dem Sensor sieht man eigentlich keinerlei Abdruck. Das ist dann wie so ein glattes Bild, weil man ja eben die Rillen gefüllt hat. Man muss halt ein bisschen Nerven mitbringen, weil in der Regel der Sachbearbeiter auf dem Meldeamt dann nicht zuerst sagt, na gut, dann drücke ich den keine Fingerknopf, sondern man probiert es dann nochmal, dann resetten die meistens normal den Computer, weil sie denken, der Sensor ist genau. Manchmal muss man sich die Hände waschen.
Wir hatten auch schon den Fall, dass tatsächlich jemand die Hände waschen muss. Das Gute halt dran, irgendwie Sekundenkleber hält halt relativ gut. Das heißt irgendwie auch Hände waschen. Also man kann da gerne drauf eingehen und sich kurz die Hände waschen und dann drauflegen, es wird trotzdem nicht funktionieren.
Zwei Gipsarme sind natürlich auch eine Möglichkeit. Ich habe keinen Scherz gemacht.
Was ist denn, wenn ich mir jetzt einfach auf die Zehen Fingerabdruckattrappen klebe?
Das ist eine wirklich interessante Frage.
Ist das eine Straftat oder sowas? Dokumenten?
Das müssen wir tatsächlich mal, ich kann mir das durchaus vorstellen, müsste man tatsächlich mal einen Juristen befragen. Was wir uns als Lösung überlegt haben, ist tatsächlich die Fußabdrücke, sich auf die Finger zu kleben. Weil das sind immer noch Abdrücke von deinem Körper, die aber trotzdem nicht erkannt werden können. Das heißt, da ist die Behauptung, dass es dann eventuell Dokumentenfeschung ist, vielleicht ausgehebelt, aber tatsächlich am besten mal den Juristen dazugefragt.
Tatsächlich sind die Sachbearbeiter angehalten, nach Attrappen zu gucken.
Tatsächlich?
Da sind sie sogar angewiesen. Das heißt, es gibt eine gewisse Reaktion darauf, dass wir den nun öffentlich gemacht haben. Wir kennen zumindest, also ich persönlich kenn zwei Fälle, die mit Attrappen durchkamen. Ich persönlich hab, also da wär ich glaube ich nicht mutig genug, mich dabei erwischen zu lassen, wäre mir ganz schön peinlich. Und man sieht es schon, dass man eine gute, sehr dünne Attrappe hat. Weiß nicht genau, aber wer da Nerven hat und irgendwie cool genug ist, bitteschön.
Okay, haben wir noch eine Frage von Fui, hallo?
Du hast noch eine Frage? Ja, und zwar, ich warte schon seit Ewigkeiten auf, dass das Thema wieder dran ist, weil ich hab nicht das Problem, ich bin sehbehindert und ruf gerade, ich empfindliche, muss von daher eine starke Töne drinnen tragen. Da ist ja gerade Fotos, da ist das so eine Sache. Und ich frag mich, wie soll ich das ehren, wenn man ausweist, abgelaufen ist, ich einen neuen brauche, wie soll ich denn diese geforderte Foto hinkriegen?
Du solltest auf jeden Fall als Ausnahme durchkommen. Also wenn man halt glaubhaft machen kann, zum Beispiel wenn man keine Fingerabdrücke hat, dann kann man auch einfach keine Fingerabdrücke abgeben. Genauso gut, wenn du halt tatsächlich drauf angewiesen bist, diese Brille zu tragen, können sie dir einfach nicht vorschreiben, diese Brille für ein Foto abzunehmen, das ist einfach so.
Ich meine, das haben sie mal gemacht, bei einer damals Polizeisicherheit, wo ich rufgenommen wurde. Aber eben die Nauderwei hat ja ein Problem. Ich hatte kein Auge offen, weil eben das Licht.
Also generell sind natürlich Brillenträger, es hat aber auch noch andere Aspekte, also Bartträger sind ähnlich, oder Leute mit Piercings oder Tätowierungsgesicht, die sind natürlich schon lange ein Problem. Weil natürlich, die Brille ist natürlich für so eine Gesichtserkennungssoftware ein interessantes Merkmal, wo sie dran hängen bleibt. Nun haben sie sich aber insgesamt so geeinigt, dass Brillenträger auf ihren Fotos generell, jetzt unabhängig davon, dass du sozusagen ja eigentlich nur ein anderes Problem als nur die Brille hast, die sollen die Brille aufbehalten, auch dass man mit der fotografiert wird. Natürlich darf man das in dem, wegen meiner Zeitraum von zehn Jahren, dann auch nicht ändern.
Also das zeigt halt schon eindeutig, wie sinnlos eigentlich große Teile dieser Forderungen sind.
Das heißt, wenn du deine Brille änderst, wenn die aufgenommen wird, genau.
Dann müssen wir nicht drüber diskutieren, das ist tatsächlich irgendwie...
Aber auch genau die Diskriminierung, die wir natürlich schon lange anprangern, also vor allen Dingen männliche Menschen sind ja meistens mit Bart ähnlich, die sollte man halt dann auch nicht ändern in zehn Jahren. Es ist manchmal, es ist so lächerlich eigentlich.
Okay, Free, deine Frage ist beantwortet dann?
Genau, auf jeden Fall darauf beharren, dass... Ich hab auch schon einen Fall gehabt, wo halt jemand seinen Mundwinkel nach unten verzungen hat, um halt so eine Erkrankung zu simulieren. Und hat tatsächlich auch damit durchgekommen. Also irgendwie, normalerweise darfst du ja wirklich einen neutralen Gesichtsausdruck, und er hat halt irgendwie so einen hängenden Mundwinkel emuliert. Und wenn man halt einfach nur persistent irgendwie nerft und sagt, es geht halt nicht anders, dann wird auch die Sachbearbeiterin oder Sachbearbeiter nicht sagen, aber du spielst das doch jetzt bloß, sondern du musst halt einfach nur glaubhaft sein.
Und den Chip-Tec-Prozess war irgendwie kurz wie Gruwelle, ne?
Nein, empfehlen wir nicht so, gibt einen, also gibt einen Brandfleck, man kann damit trotzdem weiter reisen, aber dann stellen sie blöde Fragen an der Grenze.
Es gibt den sogenannten RFID-Zapper, kann man relativ einfach aus einer 1D-Kamera selber bauen.
Sollte man aber nicht in der Nähe von Herzrhythmachern anwenden, wenn ich richtig informiert bin.
Ja, wahrscheinlich nicht direkt drauf falten, aber wenn du halt irgendwie nicht so bastlerisch begabt bist, kannst du auch gerne mal irgendwie im Berliner Club vorbeikommen und dann...
Ich merke, ich komme zuerst wahrscheinlich mal um den Workshop bei euch. Irgendwie nicht drumherum.
Ach, da fällt uns ein, da könnten wir gleich mal einen Termin ankündigen.
Okay, warte, weil die Zeit jetzt langsam wieder knapp wird. Vielen Dank erstmal für die Fragen. Wir verabschieden uns von dir. Bis dann. Und genau, wir machen gleich noch die Terminankündigung. Vorher wollten wir noch zwei kurze Sachen besprechen, also die eigentlich länger dauern sollten, aber es hat wieder viel zu lange gedauert. In Hamburg gab es auch irgendwas mit Fingerabdrücken an Schulen?
Ja, wir haben natürlich wahrgenommen, dass vor ein paar Wochen dann plötzlich die Lokalpresse in Hamburg berichtete, dass sie für kleine Kinder an Grundschulen, für die Essenausgabe dort biometrische Fingerabdrucksensoren einsetzen. Das ging so ein bisschen, ich glaube, das war bundesweit eigentlich nicht berichtet. Es ging so ein bisschen wie Presse. Tatsächlich ist dann auch eine Abordnung, da sind wir mal hingefahren. Wir wollten uns auch einfach mal ansehen, was die für Sensoren haben. Uns war auch nicht klar, wie klein die Kinder sind.
Also fast sechs bis sieben, acht Jahre.
So richtig kleine Kinder. Und dann aber auch Gesprächssuchen mit den Elterninitiativen und mit der Schulbehörde. Da haben wir natürlich gleich gelernt, dass wenn die Presse darüber berichtet, die auch sehr ablehnend waren, dann sind sie tatsächlich aus der Grundschule geworfen worden, obwohl wir ja nur mal einen Blick werfen wollten auf die Sensoren. Die waren da schon ziemlich gereizt. Aber die Elterninitiativen in Hamburg sind mittlerweile schon sehr aufmerksam geworden. Und die Schulbehörde, mit der wir dann auch noch mal Kontakt hatten, die sind jetzt auch nicht gerade die Biometriebefürworter. Wir gehen davon aus, dass die wahrscheinlich wieder abschaffen. Wir wollen da schon dranbleiben. Aber das ist natürlich gerade für kleine Kinder, die daran zu gewöhnen, so eine Biometrie-Sensoren zu benutzen, als wäre das eine Selbstverständlichkeit, das fanden wir doch kritisch.
Das ist ja auch der Hintergedanke bei Personalausweisen, bei den Reisepässen, tatsächlich die Bevölkerung an dieses automatische Erfassbare identifizieren von Menschen zu gewöhnen.
Jetzt, das also zu dem einen und der andere Punkt ist, ihr habt ja gesagt, so viel gewisse Anwendung ist das schon vorstellbar, also Warmwasserzubereitung und Bad für jedes einzelne Familienmitglied. Woran wird denn jetzt noch geforscht, sagen wir? Oder andersrum gefragt, welches Biometriemerkmal-Scan-Gerät wird Starbucks nächstes Jahr kaputt machen?
Also nicht erst nächstes Jahr, sondern ich habe gerade von einem Freund von mir gehört, der hat einen WN-Abdruckscanner, bei sich auf Arbeit zu stehen. Und das ist natürlich so, also wo ich bisher sage, macht es halt am meisten Sinn. Also was ich halt vorhin schon kurz angesprochen habe, halt so Merkmale, die man halt überall hinterlässt, wie Fingerabdrücke an Biergläsern oder dein Gesicht, was man halt einfach im Laufen fotografieren kann. Das ist halt denkbar ungeeignet für wirklich Sicherung von Geräten oder von Zutrittsmöglichkeiten. Die Vene, da ist es halt so, dass du dieses Venenmuster halt nicht hinterlässt.
An der Hand, also man muss sich vorstellen, dass es um die Hand geht. Hat so Handvenenmuster.
Wird da dann irgendwie ein ganz helles Licht durch?
Genau, also das funktioniert so, dass du halt mit Infrarotlicht, einer gewissen Wellenlänge halt die Hand durchstrahlst. Und halt dieses venöse Blut hat halt einen gewissen Absorbtionskoeffizienten. Das heißt irgendwie halt genau dort, wo das venöse Blut durchgießt, wird halt das Infrarotlicht aufgenommen. Das heißt, es wird dann dunkel erscheint im Bild. Und das ist halt dann auch ähnlich wie halt die Fingerabdrücke. Dann hast du halt dieses Venenmuster, was halt sehr eindeutig für einen Menschen, also für jeden Menschen sein sollte, ist halt auch noch nicht so richtig doll lang bekannt und irgendwie noch keine guten Studien dazu. Aber das prinzipiell ist das halt ein Verfahren, wo ich sagen würde, das hat durchaus Chancen, halt irgendwie sicherer zu sein als Fingerabdrücke und Gesichtserkennung, weil einfach halt dieses Merkmal nicht hinterlässt. Auf der anderen Seite muss auch klar gesagt werden, wenn du auf irgendeine Art und Weise dieses Venenmuster, also wenn du da rankommst, sei es jetzt halt dadurch, dass du das gespeicherte Merkmal irgendwie rausextrahierst aus dem Sensor oder du halt auf andere Art und Weise rankommst, wirst du auch die Möglichkeit haben, eine Art Rappe zu bauen. Also davon gehe ich halt ganz stark aus, werde ich mir dann die nächsten Wochen und Monate mal näher angucken.
Also das ist überhaupt nochmal die ganze spannende Frage bei der Biometrie, ob man das an den Stellen, wo sie gespeichert ist, nochmal auslesen kann.
Also das ist ja tatsächlich auch die Frage mit der Touch ID, also mit dem neuen iPhone, wo die Fingerabdrücke gespeichert werden, wie sie gespeichert werden, in welcher Form, wie sie gesichert sind. Auf jeden Fall nochmal ein großes Feld. Und wenn da jemand Bock hat, das zu machen, also wir haben jetzt vom Club aus ein Telefon.
Wenn das jemand auseinandernehmen will, meinst du?
Wenn jemand Bock hat, das auseinanderzunehmen, dann steht das durchaus zur Verfügung.
Aber ich glaube, er wird sich wohl meinen müssen, so wie jetzt im Wettbewerb. Also die Fragen haben sich natürlich auch schon bei dem Melderempter gestellt. Da war das zum Beispiel so, dass die Frage aufkam, ob ein Sensor, der wurde mit so einem USB-Kabel angeschlossen. Also da könnte man natürlich auch nochmal gucken, auf dem Übertragungsweg kann man die da mitschneiden. Das ist ein sinnloses Zufall dahinter.
Also ich meine, die ist einfach mal nicht sicher in dem Fall.
Also die Frage kommt mal wieder, aber ich glaube, die Spannbreite der biometrischen Erkennungssysteme ist auch deutlich weiter geworden. Also vielfach werden so sogenannte multimodalen Systeme beworben für wirkliche Sicherheitsanwendungen. Und multimodal bedeutet einfach nur, dass man mehr als ein biometrisches Merkmal nimmt. Nimmt man, weiß ich nicht, die Stimme oder die Finger ab.
Also das beste Beispiel ist tatsächlich Gesichtserkennung mit Spracherkennung. Dass du halt das Gesicht praktisch siehst, dass der Mund sich bewegt und gleichzeitig irgendwie noch ein gewisses gesprochenes Wort sagen musst.
Das funktioniert tatsächlich auch?
Das gibt's irgendwie. Also es funktioniert anscheinend nicht so gut, dass es halt gut angewendet werden kann.
Also Spracherkennung meine ich.
Also Sprechererkennung, das ist ein Unterschied.
Ja klar. Das gibt aber auch, wenn man mal über die Jahre auf die CeBIT geht und sich so ansieht, was die verschiedenen Firmen anbieten, alles Mögliche. Also man kann ja viele hundert Merkmale am menschlichen Körper vermessen, die sehr individuell sind.
Also das ist das beste Beispiel, fand ich irgendwie, Ohrform.
Ja, also Volumen des Innenohres.
Also die Schallreflektion. Sie haben tatsächlich ein Telefon genommen mit einem Mikrofon und einem, ähm, das Gegenteil. Lautsprecher? Lautsprecher. Haben mit dem Lautsprecher halt irgendwie weißes Rauschen in das Ohr reinprojiziert und haben die Rückreflektion gemessen und die ist halt auch pro Ohrform unterschiedlich. Und das ist natürlich auch ein sehr nettes Merkmal, natürlich irgendwie, wenn man halt ein Foto vom Ohr oder einen 3D-Abdruck vom Ohr macht, kann man dann auch das Ohr nachbauen, aber da gibt's halt wirklich verschiedenste.
Also man stellt sich halt einfach Ohrzugang vor, man hält dann sein Handy ans Ohr und das weißes ist das Ohr des Benutzers, so ist es gemeint. Aber der Mensch hat halt unglaublich viele solche Merkmale.
Was ist denn mit ihr, weil man es aus seinen Fiction Filmen kennt, mit Auge?
Ja, diese Irriden, wenn man jetzt versucht, Muster in den Irriden festzustellen, das gibt es natürlich auch, wurde auch schon offiziell getestet.
Also es ist sicherheitstechnisch durchaus akzeptabel. Da ist halt der Convenience-Fall komplett weg, weil es halt viel zu aufwendig ist. Du musst halt wirklich dein Auge davor halten für mehrere Sekunden. Beim Augenhintergrund leuchtet der sogar mit dem Laser rein, was halt viele Leute nicht wollen.
Was wird denn da genau gemacht?
Also Iris-Erkennung ist tatsächlich auch nur eine Kamera, also auch ein Infrarotbereich. Das heißt, du strahlst halt mit Infrarotlicht rein, machst halt ein hochauflösendes Bild von der Iris und extrahierst dann halt Merkmale, genauso wie vom Fingerabdruck, die im Minuzum extrahiert werden, machst du halt dann wieder die verschiedenen Mister auf der Iris.
Das ist ein Teil des offiziellen Tests, also da ist die Bundesrepublik tatsächlich in einem offiziellen Test, damals die Biop-2-Studie, untersucht, ob man eventuell Iris-Erkennung für die Pässe nehmen könnte.
Gibt's auch am Flughafen, also Frankfurt hat die Vielfliegerselektierung, also die Biometrie dort auch mit Iris-Erkennung gemacht. Was ich auf jeden Fall noch sagen wollte, wo es halt jetzt um Reisepässe und automatisch Abfertigung geht, also sie haben ja damals bei der Einführung immer behauptet, man kann halt zwar Fingerabdrücke faken, aber man wird sie halt niemals an Grenzen einsetzen können, weil halt immer ein Beamter daneben steht, der halt irgendwie guckt, ob dann gefaketer Finger, also eine Attrappe, drauf ist, was sie tatsächlich jetzt vor wenigen Wochen irgendwie angekündigt haben, dass sie automatische Grenzkontrollen, was wir halt schon bei der Einführung gesagt haben, sie werden irgendwann dazu übergehen, wenn sie diese Merkmal aufnehmen, ist es dafür geeignet, das automatisch durchzuführen. Und genau das wollen sie jetzt auch tun.
Andere Länder machen das sogar schon, aber bei uns ist es jetzt noch relativ neu, da haben sie ja eine Weile getestet. Und jetzt, dass diese ganze, das ganze Gerede, was sie uns am Anfang erzählt haben, das ist alles nur ein zusätzliches Merkmal, ist jetzt plötzlich dann doch wieder eine automatische Abfertigung, wo kein Mensch mehr draufguckt.
Aus der Abteilung. Wir haben es euch ja schon immer gesagt. Präsentierten wir den Chaos Computer Club zum Thema Biometrie und Fingerabdrücke. Ihr habt noch eine Ankündigung. Zwei. Noch zwei Ankündigungen.
Also der eine ist, wer sich dafür jetzt näher interessiert und vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen selber probieren will, der kann nächste Woche, und in Berlin ist, kann nächste Woche Donnerstag, also am 3. Oktober, das ist ein Feiertag, abends, wahrscheinlich so um 7 oder 8 Uhr, in den Berliner CCCB kommen. Der ist in der Mitte, in der Marienstraße 11. Da machen wir einen Datengarten und Starbuck kann da sozusagen nochmal live mit anfassen.
Ja, also ich werde halt auf jeden Fall irgendwie nicht, also den kompletten Vorgang einfach nicht, weil ätzen kann man da nicht, aber zumindest mal wird das iPhone da sein. Ich werde ein bisschen erzählen, was ich gemacht habe, ein bisschen Filme, das Video zeigen.
Haben wir da noch einen Sapper da?
Wir haben auf jeden Fall auch den Sapper da. Das heißt, wenn ihr Interesse an dem Thema habt, dann kommt einfach vorbei und wir können da gerne noch drüber diskutieren oder ihr könnt halt irgendwie auch mal ausprobieren, wie euer Finger aussieht.
Kleiner Workshop mit dem Typen, der das iPhone 5S kaputt gemacht hat. Kann man mal machen, finde ich.
Ja, man kann da durchaus was lernen und immer fragenlos werden und so. Die zweite Ankündigung, die wollen wir auf keinen Fall vergessen, ist natürlich, dass wir Ende des Jahres, nämlich vom 27. bis 30. Dezember, den 30. Chaos Communication Congress machen in Hamburg, in dem großen Kongresscenter am Bahnhof, wie heißt der Bahnhof noch? Dammtor. Wofür wir natürlich sehr gerne einladen wollen. Wir haben eine neue Rekordanzahl von Einreichungen, die derzeit durchgesehen werden und wir können jetzt schon sagen, wir werden wirklich, also wir werden ziemlich fantastische Programme haben, gemessen an den Einreichungen. Wir haben jetzt schon Schwierigkeiten, dass wir so viele Ablehnungen rausschicken müssen. Aber wir hoffen, dass wir das Programm erweitern dürfen.
Also für alle, die letztes Jahr nicht dabei gewesen sind, weil im VU ist ja nicht mehr in Berlin, es ist in Hamburg und es ist ja doof dort. Es war letztes Jahr schon cool und es wird dieses Jahr einfach total außen werden. Also kommt hin.
Also kleines Treffen am Donnerstag, großes Treffen gegen Ende des Jahres. Zwischendurch immer mal wieder, nämlich im letzten Donnerstag im Monat ein Chaosradio hier im Blue Moon. Starbuck, Frau Doktor Konstanze Kurz, vielen Dank. Wir verabschieden uns an dieser Stelle, übergeben gleich an Flo Heiler, der hier im Nullfight euch mit ein bisschen Punkmusik bewerfen wird. Mir bleibt nur noch eine Sache zusammen. Mein Name ist Markus Richter und ihr macht bitte immer schön eure Backups und lasst euch nicht überwachen.